à peine arrivée en bavière les
dirigeants des pays du g7 ont donné le
ton envoyer un signal de solidarité aux
ukrainiens et un message ferme à la
russie quelques heures avant le début du
sommet moscou a bombardé un quartier du
centre de kiev
nous devons rester soudés parce que
poutine espère depuis le début que d'une
manière ou d'une autre l'otan et le
chétif mais ça n'a pas été le cas si
nous ne ne sais pas en
ce premier jour du sommet londres
washington ottawa et tokyo ont annoncé
l'arrêt d'achat d'or russe l'objectif de
ce sommet c'est bien sûr renforcé les
sanctions contre moscou est ce le plus
rapidement possible depuis le début de
la guerre l'union européenne a déjà mis
en place si paquet de sanctions young
thing you do to provide l'union
européenne va continuer d'apporter une
aide solide à l'ukraine un support
financier humanitaire et politique qui
botte l'ukraine mixmo mais l'ukraine a
besoin de plus d'aidé encore monts et
nous nous engageons à lui fournir
davantage de moyens financiers et de
soutien politique mais pour le premier
ministre britannique pas question de se
précipiter
solution négociée maintenant en ukraine
risquerait de prolonger l'instabilité
mondiale
le sauver si en allemagne avec les pays
les plus riches du monde nous nous
concentrons sur le trend est soit la
façon de maintenir cette collection de
se tient à un moment où vous savez le
peuple et les politiciens sont fatigués
du conflit
comment accentuer les sanctions sur le
régime de poutine sans impacter le reste
du monde c'est à ce dilemme que les
membres du g7 vont tenter de répondre
ces trois prochains jours ils vont aussi
plancher sur la crise alimentaire en
cours la veille vingt mille personnes
ont manifesté dans les rues de munich et
appelle les dirigeants du g7 à agir
davantage pour la pauvreté et le
dérèglement climatique
les chefs d'état évoque déjà la création
d'un club pour le climat afin de mieux
coordonner la tarification du carbone
entre autres